good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast this special episode of the
toast is presented by State Farm like a
good neighbor State Farm is there thank
you State Farm for sponsoring a gorgeous
Monday episode not only is it a gorgeous
Monday episode because I have returned
from Las Vegas and boy do I have things
to say it is also jacn F's birthday okay
everybody in studio clap it's Jackie's
birthday hey Jack how you doing I'm
doing good I'm feeling super special
that State Farm wanted to sponsor my
birthday episode and that is that's why
they called they said we hear there's a
big birthday coming up yeah and Jake
like called me personally and he was
like wow he was like happy birth direct
line happy birthday Jakey from State
Farm happy birthday Jax how do you feel
I feel good I mean it's just it's so
much pressure to like have a special day
no it's not horrible like and I'm trying
to just like be really present in the
day like every
few 30 minutes an hour I'll be like oh
it's my birthday birthday how wonderful
I'm trying to like appreciate any
special moments and it actually has been
made more special by the fact that
yesterday was Daylight savings so to I'm
getting like more birthday in my day
because we all woke up at 700 today and
usually we wake up at 8: so I'm getting
the extra hour for my day of birth and
so far it's been a pleasant day I don't
have anything crazy planned the one
thing that I wanted which I'm getting
which is all that I want is a massage oh
and I didn't know if it was going to
happen but then yesterday I found
someone who can do an at home massage
cuz I can't leave the house uh and I'm
so excited because I am a broken woman
like I love that I love physically I am
ailing so I'm really excited about that
and then you know what I'm doing today
and this is kind of I feel like what
people wouldn't expect from like
birthday plans cuz it's always like oh
we'll go to a restaurant and we'll order
something special I'm kind of turning
the birthday on its head oh my God what
are you doing I'm making a
chili you making a chili day chili I
absolutely love that for you the word
chili like does send a shiver down my
spine cuz you're in a chili Scandal of
your own but let me just say why I
decided to make a chili for my birth
except I'm sure people are like Jack why
do you want to cook well first of all
I'll have like the chili will be going
all day it'll get like so excited such a
good vibe I don't want to order in I
don't enjoy ordering in so I want to
have a home-cook
meal why not chili and I can like
prepare it right after we finish the
toast and be done with the work and then
by the time it's dinner time like my
dinner will be ready I'll have a Hearty
dinner and that's what makes me happy is
having chili so like why not on my
birthday that's beautiful I love that
chili has kind of just become like a
Cornerstone of our of our joy and our
happiness it's really something that
booys the both of us yeah and but it
took a dark ter for you yesterday and I
know how you feel because I've had my
own chili scandal in the past no and so
it's funny that like chili is this kind
of joyous thing in our lives and we both
kind of have trauma Associated to it we
do but it's like the chili will prevail
but tell everyone what you're going
through and and how you're feeling well
the first first thing is how for anyone
who might be new here and Jackie
Jackie's story is actually really really
beautiful um she put out a vlog on our
patreon um because we're always talking
about chili and people are always asking
for like recipes and stuff so she did a
vlog like making a chili and I don't
think there's ever been more backlash
within our community than there was that
day I remember I was in Biz and I was
like just enjoying my life and I looked
at my phone and I'm like oh my God our
business is burning our business is
ending it was a flop people did not like
me they did not like the Vlog and they
did not like the recipe they thought it
was like not special enough when I like
I wasn't saying this is like a crazy
chili I'm like this is my standard chili
and so to be honest I think maybe you
know up until yesterday like I was on
the side of the people like I was I
stood with them I saw them I I I I felt
what they were saying and I had to
experience you know the same thing you
experienced in order for me to realize
like people need to grow the [__] up and
shut the [__] up about Chile okay yeah
so Claudia put out her video and I could
tell you put a lot of love and care into
your video and you were excited about
your video and your chili which is
exactly how I felt when I did my chili
blog I was enjoying my day taking
everyone along with me like sure it
wasn't the most groundbreaking content
but it was pleasant I felt Y and Claudia
put forth her video in her chili and she
was brutally rebuffed people saying
that's not chili that's meat sauce
people what about it wasn't chili people
saying you're shouldn't be eating chili
with a fork and to that I say grab a
spoon grab a spoon um honestly it was
very it was disheartening it was
upsetting and most of all it was
confusing because people the general
consensus in my comment section uh and
by the way Ben was responding to every
single comment fighting for his life the
general consensus was that what we made
was not a chili and it was taco meat it
literally wasn't I've been saying I've
been saying tury doesn't like chili tur
likes taco meat like that's how she
likes her chili she doesn't like it
soupy and I've also been saying that
chili is more personal than comedy more
personal than food more personal than
poetry more personal than Insurance
thanks State Farm for sponsoring this
episode and so the way why don't you add
it to the list of things you were right
about
like I get you I me and B just kept like
looking at each other and we're like
what about this isn't chil I I think the
general consensus was that it wasn't
technically chili cuz we didn't put any
chili powder in it why didn't you put
chili powder in it I didn't watch the I
watch the whole thing but only half with
volume Ben just like his secret blend of
herbs and spices doesn't include chili
It's got cumin paprika you know yeah I
already have a list on my phone of
things that are personal oh my God our
lists are so poignant comedy food poetry
travel insurance
books insurance and chili yeah that's
kind of that's where I'll leave it you
know I don't really want to like feed
into the negativity of you know people
trying to bring me down cuz I'm I'm just
such a light you are so did you enjoy
your chili I did it was it came with a
side of backlash but I enjoyed the chili
The Taste was superb superb yeah and I
just want to say credit to myself
because when I made my chili Vlog I also
went above and beyond and I made a
recipe card and I put it together
finally my chili recipe down on paper
and I haven't made a chili in so long
that I forgot what what kind of chili I
like and I went and self-referenced my
recipe card and that's the recipe I will
be following so thank you pasted me it's
amazing when you know you can reference
or not reference your own work and I'm
feeling really excited to follow my own
recipe well happy birthday ja I can't
think of a better way to spend your
birthday than
together you know chitchatting girly
girl chitchat girly girl chitchat
presented by Steve Farm no I I seriously
couldn't and think of a better way with
a future of Chile in my future so
today's episode's going to be fabulous
everybody wants the Bravo con recap I
just got back from Los Vegas I was
there Las Vegas I think in today's
episode we're going to talk a lot about
Viva Las Vegas and you can't say LV you
can't say those words if you're not
going to sing it so true I think that's
a fair rule for today so Jackson I
thought you know we'll do an entire
Bravo con recap as our first story and
then of course the rest of the Fast Five
and we got a little surprised that the
end of the episode um for everybody
maybe it's like it's like a birthday
Extravaganza surprise everything is just
coming up birthday everything's coming
up J Jakey from State Farm so let's dive
into the bravon recap I got back from
Vegas on Saturday night like in the
middle of the night um shall we I have a
lot to say into the stories I have a lot
to say so I think without further Ado
without further Ado About My Birthday
Chile though I might Circle back to it I
make no promises here are the fast di
stories that you need to
know okay so Bravo con this is my second
Bravo conon the first time I went I
moderated a panel which was obviously
like such an honor and very um exciting
but I didn't really get to experience
the con because I was like backstage
like working reading reading off Kurds
right you do love Kurds I do love Kurds
but this time was actually like better
because I got to go and like walk
through the convention I had like a
whole ticket and I went with State Farm
was the brand that brought me and they
had like this really kind of sick
activation very summerhouse era um and
it was just really cool to like go they
put so much effort and like thought into
all like the entire convention I didn't
really get to see that the last time the
last time it was also in New York which
was obviously so easy for me but this I
think like going to a different state
like everybody there you were more
immersed yeah no and it really felt like
a convention like just walking through
like the hotel lobby everybody was
wearing like their t-shirts and you
could tell like people were just there
for Bravo kind there was also a lot
going on in Vegas that weekend but for
the most part everyone was there for
Bravo con it was just like very exciting
it made it like it made it a lot more I
think exciting to a it be in another
city that is not my hometown and B to
get to go with State Farm and just like
literally walk through like I got to see
everybody's like merch booths there was
just like a lot going on and the cool
thing about bravon is like the talent
like there's so many Bravo Liberties
they literally just walk the floor like
you don't need to you know get a meet
and greet to meet a you just walk around
you'll see a million people from every
franchise and what I really love and I
feel like always cite this as a
reference is what I really like about
Bravo con is that it's not just active
Bravo
Liberties and I always cite how like the
shs of sunset people you can add that to
the list I I like that they like include
former shows former Housewives former
CES so it was like really sick to see
everyone and I was so happy to see my
shaza Sunset girly girls there so who
did you see who did you spend the most
time with I spent the most time Loki
with Jake from State
Farm wow and I have
let me tell you okay first of all if
you're watching on YouTube I'm going to
put up a picture of me and Jake's firm
safe Farm you could see like we had this
sort of like electric
connection tell me more um when I tell
you whenever I like meet someone famous
like everybody like from high school
they call me and they text me I never
got more texts in my life seriously than
meeting Jake from State far that is so
funny but I feel that even when I saw
the pictures and the content like that's
a big celeb no it's a big celeb and I
actually like got to spend like some
downtime with him and I had so many
questions for him cuz he's such an
interesting level of Fame where he's
arguably like one of the most
recognizable people in the world yeah
everybody knows him he's so famous but
it's not like traditional Fame where you
have like a movie or a book or whatever
like where people know you from it's
kind of this different level of Fame and
when I tell you he could not have been
nicer he's so normal he's because he's
really like a regular guy that's the
yeah that's comforting he was so nice
he's very
handsome he's very handsome and honestly
I I just feel like we were like doing a
bunch of like things at the activation
but I really was like just trying to get
some downtime with him like asking him a
bunch of questions about you know his
life and he was you know an upand
cominging actor he wanted ATT and this
role this is really the role of a
lifetime the role of a lifetime just
transformed Med his life yeah I just I
was obsessed with Jake from safe
farm and by the way Jackie line of
people to take a picture he was like
doing a mean greet at the they they
built this like big house in the middle
of Bravo con State Farm did and it was
meant I think to look like you know the
summerh house house because it was very
Hampton's very Coastal grandmother there
was a pool and it said summer should be
fun um not a real pool sorry like a fake
pool but whatever um and people
literally like lined up when I walked in
I was like oh my God who's here maybe
it's like you know Paige dorbo and Paige
dorbo actually was there but it was Jake
from sa formb wow who have thought to go
all the way to Viva Las Vegas honestly
it was most taken with Jake but I was
very taken no so was everyone Jackie
everybody was calling
me I love that um so they had a really
cute activation and a lot of like Bravo
Leb stop by I saw Paige and Amanda
really like everybody's outfits it's
crazy how everybody like it's the Met
Gala for Bravo Liberties like they had
stylist they have multiple outfit
changes full Glam like it was really
insane to see up close and personal how
much effort and thought went into the
luks and everybody really looked great
yeah no it's a whole thing there's so
much news that came out from Bravo con
cuz obviously like all the stars in one
room we have Vander pump rule news um
you know some sound bites from some of
the panels you know Kyle was tearing up
about her separation with Mauricio
Erica Jane has her own little spin-off
about her Vegas show uh bet it all on
blonde that looks intense it does I was
surprised that she got a spin-off but I
love that yeah no um Shannon Mador
addresses her DUI on the stage did you
take in any of the panels in your time I
did the summerhouse one um which was
brought to you by State Farm it was it
just happened to be also sponsored by
starm um that was really interesting cuz
that was the first time and Lindsay like
actually physically saw each other s
which is so crazy and how that's where
it's like I was what I was thinking a
lot about this weekend is how meta it is
to be a Bravo Liberty cuz like you
really put your whole life out yeah this
is your real life like real
relationships fiance but it's also your
work yeah so it's like you're going to
this big work trip where you have to
live out your life yes publicly yeah
it's interesting it was also making me
think of like Paige and Craig cuz it's
like so cool that they're dating and
they're like co-workers and they both
have this big work event and they get to
go together go together no totally the
relationships like when they when it
works it's so fabulous but then when it
doesn't work Carl and Lindsay like oh my
God how awkward is that like your ex
fiance your scorned lover like a person
you probably don't hate more in the
world than than your ex fiance is
literally your coworker right but then
it also facilitates mending fences
because like look at Tom sand ofal yeah
no by the way in the mix when I was
walking around I we knew he was going to
get like booed whatever but like people
were lining up his merch by the way he
was selling like $100 merch his merch
was for sale there were people lining up
like you can't keep a Bravo liberty down
and it's like the farther you fall
almost like the higher you climb Mak
sense yeah yeah I know what you mean but
also like he is kind of good with a lot
of the cast members like even Ariana we
are seeing some of that like in the
upcoming season like I mean they're
filming together and he's still a part
of the show and they're at Bravo con and
he's but the Bravo con drama was that
they did a panel the night before they
did a panel or the night of they did a
panel apparently Shea was like spending
all night in Tom's room not like in a
sexual way but just like hanging out
when she's like ride or die for Ariana
and and like Ariana was really mad about
it that is trama but then I've also seen
like Ariana hanging out in a group
setting with sandal so I'm just I mean
she has to yeah no but there's clearly
like a
divide
interesting um I don't know if anybody
noticed I'm wearing some like new kind
of designer bracelet
I I see that's your pop of red for the
season right the State Farm Red by the
way you know that red they really do say
red is the color of the season I've I've
now been seeing it since you said it and
it's never going to be the color of my
season unless I am with State F being
sponsored by State
Farm but um I do see what you're saying
now and I do think that State Farm's
influence OB honestly they had a
friendship bracelet making station at
the State Farm thing which is so cute I
love how friendship bracelets are like
back yeah yeah they're like so of the
zist right now yeah thanks tailored so I
actually got one um from Jake I don't
know I don't want to like make my
husband what does it say it says Jake's
BFF I feel like that's him putting me in
the friend zone for sure did he make
that for you or did you make it for
yourself like we saw on your Instagram
okay don't be rude he made it for me it
says Jake's BFF then one of the
professional bracelet makers made me
this one that says good
neighbor and then I made myself one that
says turo are you a good
neighbor oh my God that's so funny that
you say that because actually this
morning I was thinking about neighbors
because I'm in this new building and I
got in the elevator and then it stopped
and picked someone up on the way down
and he was just like this older
gentleman and he was like you know ah
Monday and I was like Monday and it was
like
9:45 so he's like not that rough you
know we're both leaving the house at
9:45 I'm like totally and then I got out
of the elevator and I was like in my old
building I never sort of had that
neighborly
camaraderie yeah and that's because like
nobody lived in my old building it was
very much like a i the one time I
literally saw someone in my old building
he's like is this your primary residence
I'm like uh yeah are you calling me poor
like everybody in my building was so
rich that this was their second home you
know yeah and I was like I was like the
only slob who lived there
primarily um but then in this new
building like everybody lives there you
know it's like where people live right
where you have good neighbors like State
Farm right and I had just like a
neighborly experience this morning and I
was like this is so normal I love and
soon you're going to be bringing over a
cup of sugar right no no like may I
borrow an egg may I borrow some chili
powder I'm getting roasted on Instagram
s do you have any do you have chili
powder to spare do you have some liquid
I could put with my taco meat oh my God
I did put broth in my taco I don't want
to talk about it I have to go back in
assess and see like how much broth did
you put my recipe calls for two cups I
don't P just eyeballs at but a lot yeah
I saw the eyeball I let it simmer you
know let it simmer living in my head
rentree what that
Chopper I got it from my uh yeah from
Amazon I got a veggie Chopper is it
worth it yes cuz I'm thinking about
today all the chopping that I have to do
and I just like keep seeing you like
pushing it down on the chopper and I'm
like maybe I need a chopper it's 100%
worth it you just have to know how to
use it like I used it a little bit
incorrectly yesterday but it still saved
me at least 20 minutes but Ben wasn't
convinced because I used it incorrectly
like I put the whole bell pepper you
have to lay it flat if you want it
really small right also Ben is an expert
Chopper it's such a shame that you have
a chopper when you literally have a
chopper a human Chopper he chops so
nicely he does wait also I'm sorry the
kind of the biggest moment at braon I
totally forgot to talk about was on the
way
there um I knew that my route like the
Thursday night before Friday of bra from
New York to Vegas like I knew there
would be people on it just Viva Las
Vegas thank you um I knew there would be
housewi on it cuz I live you know
obviously in New York but there's
multiple franchises There's real housewi
of New York OG real housewi of New York
new real house of New Jersey summer
house so I knew and it really was like
there was so many toasters and just like
Bravo fans on the flight and then when
we got seated I was literally like just
minding my own business and I heard
Aaron lei's voice and had had just been
catching up on real house of New York I
heard her voice and I happened to have
her number cuz we've been put in this
chat and I texted her I was like by the
way are you on this flight and she like
turned around she was sitting right in
front of me with her husband and then
very last minute she almost missed the
flight Dolores Katana and Paulie got on
we're sitting a few rows behind me and
eron and I were just like talking then I
went to go to the bathroom and I haven't
met her but we like know each other just
from like New York Jewish energy and she
was sitting next to Abe who I love and
on my way back from the bathroom we like
were chatting and she was telling me
that she's staring this dinner and if I
wanted to come and I really was planning
on getting there Thursday night so I
could show up you know fresh-faced and
gorgeous for State Farm but you know ER
Lei invites you to a dinner and she told
me like a lot of people were going to be
there I was like okay I didn't even
bring an outfit I looked so ugly and
stupid because I really only planned for
a Friday and I was really planning on
going to bed MH whatever I wore like
some ugly shirt and a
skirt and I'm so glad I went by the way
because it was really premium like I
wasn't sure who was going to be there
you know Erin's new to the Bravo world I
don't know if she has like deep
connections to you know the OG's it was
Aaron Luchi chy Abe who I need to talk
about because like I'm obsessed with Abe
is her husband for those who don't watch
New York Legacy Meredith marks from Salt
Lake City Crystal Kung
Minkoff Jackie gold Schneider Jen
festler Jeff festler I can't believe
they literally have the same name I just
put that together um Tracy tutor for
Million Dollar Listing I think that's it
but I'm definitely forgetting someone
and it's like so
rude no I think that's it yeah that's it
um and I didn't realize it was kind of
like a meeting of the Jewish Housewives
I didn't know Crystal Kung Minkoff was a
convert love for her either no Abe aon's
husband told me all about it apparently
she's like a very you know devoted
convert love that I love that I love
that I knew her husband was to I didn't
know she converted um and it was
fabulous fabulous fabulous I really
spent most of the night talking to
Abe Erin's husband and I don't want to
like I don't want to blow you know I
don't want to blow up his spot but I
have to say something because I sat
right behind him on the plane okay do
you know what eron and a bichi does on
the
plane no no shoes no
socks is he wearing socks that he takes
off or he wore sock shoes with no socks
that's an amazing question I only saw
the raw dogs I didn't I didn't see the
unveiling of the dogs yeah but I just
thought everybody should know maybe he
wore like a loafer because that's a
comfortable travel shoe and when you
take off keep your shoes
on
like they slide on and off by the way I
just want to say on really long flights
I do take my shoes off and I always
bring a pair of like big fuzzy socks me
too but not everyone is tury other other
people have things on their mind you
know they the socks might slip through
the cracks I just thought everybody
should know
that and now we know and now you know I
had so much fun at this dinner by the
way like I was so glad I went it was one
of those things where like I went by
myself yeah and you know like going
places by yourself can be tough yeah and
in that moment I was like I really wish
Ben came with me but obviously he had to
watch the um and I was a little nervous
I'm not going to lie tury was nervous
you know I didn't know who was going to
be there I don't know like The Vibes I
wasad shy I was feeling shy I really was
I was so glad that I went everyone was
so nice like not AB Lei like making
people move and giving me the seat next
to him like so generous and I literally
spent the whole night talking to AB Lei
and Jen festler cuz I'm obsessed with
Jen festler from real hos of New Jersey
like she's so underrated I saw on your
Instagram and I agree from the show from
the show like and and I told her that I
loved her she's like no I know like my
daughter's the biggest toaster and when
you talked about me on the toast and
just said that you like loved me
everybody in my life like texted me
calling me she was like I had no idea
and she was like my daughter thought I
was so cool and so thank you and I was
obsessed I was like oh my not Jen fesler
like respecting the toast love her
respecting the hell out of the toast and
then there was like a moment where all
the housewives got together to take a
picture and obviously like I didn't get
in it and like cuz I respect like I'm
not a housewife I'm just like a loser
podcaster you
know you're just a lowly turd no I'm
like I'm not here for you know I'm not a
bra Liberty I'm here with like one of
these things is not like the other and
by the way like it's
not good or bad that you're not a house
like it just is it's just a fact like
and we can look facts in the eye let me
tell you they all were like turty get
the picture I swear they no no no I was
not going to get in the picture because
I'm not like I know where I'm not wanted
you know I'm I know where I'm not needed
it's not about not being wanted it's
about not being needed or factually
accurate it's about knowing your place
and factual accuracy is key Meredith
everybody was like tury they didn't say
tury Claudia get in get in but I did let
them get a shot without me right of
course it's like when you bring someone
to a wedding who you don't know if it's
going to last they get and I thought it
was interesting but not all I thought I
thought it was interesting like who
chose to post a picture with me and who
chose to post a picture without me name
names no I won't I won't who posted with
you um I want to say it was Jen festler
and then a bunch of people reposted Jen
festers so unbeknownst to them they
included me oh were you like on a bunch
of Bravo accounts too did you oh I don't
know I'm sure I was yeah do you have
your tags on do you see it I I do have
my tags on but I didn't look I was so
busy you know with Jake from State
firm Jake from State firm but I was
actually like you know one of those
things where you're like nervous you're
like G I don't want to go and then
you're like so happy you went yes that's
like the camber and the counselor yes
exactly I experienced exactly what the
camber experienced on the Thursday night
at Bravo con would you say Jen no Abe
was your counselor Abe was my counselor
for
sure just like shepherding you through
like you better be hungry cuz dinner is
ready I hope you like I hope you like
meatballs on top of spaghetti beautiful
it's a Timeless tale so then Friday and
Saturday I was at the convention with
State Farm and it was really um just
fabulous it really reminded me a lot of
the eras tour H because like everybody
there was just like so happy and like
this is their interest like Bravo is
definitely a hobby you know like it's a
full-time job to be keeping up with all
these shows the drama on the internet
and everybody was just wearing like how
the ER tore everybody wore like their
craziest sparkliest Ary outfit
everybody's wearing like their bravest
outfit like they all had were very
creative with like their t-shirts and
their slogans and people made their own
shirts and everyone was just so excited
to be there like
excited about this common thing you know
yeah and it was like this judgment free
zone almost I feel like people who watch
a lot of reality TV like people totally
look down on you they're like uh you
like watch that trash like and like this
was just a place where everybody could
be very
um not ruthless what's the Shameless
almost yeah with their love and
adoration and like excitement no one's
going to be like making fun of you for
being excited about something and like
you know geeking out over resap
farahan and it was really it reminded a
lot of the AR tour that's beautiful yeah
is that a good like comparison I thought
of that it is a good comparison like
everyone that's what I thought when I
was walking one common interest
unabashedly yeah that's what I was
thinking when I walked into the Aros I'm
like this is so nice like everybody who
like probably keeps a part of their like
joy and excitement like a little bit
sheltered because like for fear of
judgment you didn't have to do that at
the Aros tore and you don't have to do
it at braan either that's so great yeah
it was really honestly sick and this was
the first time they did it in Vegas and
it definitely made it more special like
and the convention center was I must
have gotten 30,000 steps in every day
like I brought so I didn't check but I
should and I'm probably like deeply
overestimating it was probably like
5,000 um I brought a pair of like Croc
sandals I'm so glad that I did I thought
maybe I was like oh I'll bring them and
if I don't need them the next day I
won't bring them so much walking like if
you want to see everything and and
compare there was a lot of walking in
New York but it was pretty much
contained you the Javit Center takes up
like three blocks this convention center
oh my God it must have been 100,000 sare
F feet oh that's so exciting yeah I like
when it's a destination everyone's like
in one the city's so big you can stay
anywhere it kind of spreads people apart
but to be like all on the trip that's so
cool I wonder if they'll do it again
there I would imagine it was successful
yeah I mean it being in New York is
obviously like way more convenient for
tury but it definitely makes it like
more special for sure and Vegas is like
I'm a I love Vegas I I don't know if
people know that about me like I I love
Vegas yeah no I love Vegas i l city in
the world I went to the casino by myself
Vegas are nowhere Vegas or nowhere I
agree how' you do at the casino I didn't
do great but I could have done a lot
worse but did you have
fun I was like by myself and I sat down
at this table with the this other guy
and he was like not like in like he
wasn't wanting to create camaraderie at
the table and I feel like the best
tables are when strangers come together
and sort of
create bonds and we're all on the same
team like we're all playing against the
dealer we're not playing against each
other because I was playing Blackjack
and he was not interested in like even
remotely making a connection with me and
that was that was it took away from the
fun for sure so in that sense he was
unlike Jake from State Farm precisely
maybe he already knew you had a best
friend maybe maybe he saw the bracelet
that said Jake's BFF Jake and me and
three Jake and you and Aaron and I mean
and Abe four and Aaron four yeah five
and Jen fesler totally what a crew yeah
well thanks for the recap I'm so glad
that you went and that you had you know
boots on the ground you were able to
tell us what we're missing cuz
everyone's talking about Bravo Khan this
weekend no they were so like you just
needed to walk around to witness stuff
it's not like all this stuff was
happening behind the scenes you know
right it was actually cool like when you
were walking between like there like
these huge rooms I was in the it's all
happening room very shaay but when you
walk between these big convention
centers there's literally just like
stages in the Middle with like mini
panels breakout sessions then there was
like the big stage that's where the
summerhouse one was that's where like
the big New Jersey ones but then they
had these sort of breakout sessions and
there was like aers like d you know you
just had to walk around to see stuff it
was actually cool and for the most part
every Bravo Liberty like wants to meet
the fans they're not like divas and like
walking they're coming there to be a
part of it like it's so they were taking
pictures with everyone I did see um like
some Tik Tok drama like people calling
out Bravo celebrities who like weren't
being friendly oh I didn't see or who
required you to like purchase something
before taking a picture some people like
did their meet and greets at their mooch
mooch
birth at their merch Booth merch Booth
um and it was like encouraged to
purchase but not required and some
people it was required and that rubbed a
lot of people the wrong way but I feel
like if you're a boba Liberty who's
doing that it's so unbrand that it
actually doesn't harm your brand I agree
and it really depends on who it is but
you can get away with it being a diva is
on brand 100% so if someone's like
walking around pretending like they're
too good for pictures it's like that's
interesting and and of itself it is but
you know let me tell you State Farm was
very L Fair like Amanda Pula and Paige
dorbo and Jake from safe arm no purchase
required like they just came so many I
met so many toasters the Bravo toaster
like overlap the vent diagram is just oh
my God it's a circle so I felt like
really good to be amongst like-minded
individuals that's great I'm actually
all caught up on my bravo right now I'm
caught up on Beverly Hills and I'm
caught up on Southern Charm and things
are starting to get a little crazy I
finished
Rooney all the Rooney ladies were there
except Jenna
Lions I feel like that pretty much
confirms like she's not coming back is
that what people are saying yeah when
the last time she went on watch Robin
live people said like her and Andy like
talking about the season was very
conclusive like do you think she was
right for the show
no and do you I think she would agree
and people were like acting treating her
differently than everyone else yeah it's
almost like when Denise Richards came on
that's like the same level I I I think
it's a good comparison and she got no
special
treatment yeah Jenna got so much special
treatment that to the point where it
made it uninteresting and she also
didn't
really open up and she did open up about
certain stuff but it wasn't like
interesting she didn't open up with the
ladies in terms of like being real
friends with them I think and I I I
think the the excitement of a being gen
Alliance wore off very quickly to the
point where she's a housewife now and
she's not cutting it yeah yeah that
happens with everyone like you get a big
name but it's like okay that's
interesting for an episode but like what
do you bring to the show it doesn't last
past like three episodes honestly yeah
so I feel like her not coming when
everybody else did Jessel Brin Aon I
feel
like it's pretty much confirmation she's
not coming back I don't think she liked
it either like she didn't like to talk
about it in the Press she wore jeans to
the reunion like fair not everything is
for everyone yeah is that crazy she wore
jeans to a reunion Andy said something
it's not crazy cuz it's her like right
no if there's very few people who could
get away with that yeah if it was like
an OC housewife wearing jeans like that
would be wild but like oh she wore jeans
of tha fashion yeah cuz she is fashion I
will say also it being in Vegas it was a
little chaotic in New York because like
it was only so big so every time a panel
ended people would run out and then it
was almost like a little chaotic this
one was so big like there it was very
spread out like there were seats there
wasn't standing room like it was very
civilized yeah it was I think it was
better I think it was better
everything's bigger in Vegas and they
went bigger too they did like the
braavos there where Andy basically like
hosted the Golden Globes and gave out
Awards a bunch of people were up for
awards and he like roasted everyone it
was actually it was really good great
well thanks for going and covering in
and thanks for safe farm for bringing
our girl making sure that she got
brought back all the tea all the
bracelets all the memories shout out to
stay firm because I probably wouldn't
have went without them so
because like like a good neighbor State
firm is there was Jake impressed with
your singing he was actually I I think
he's just like a really nice guy you
know yeah so we made like some content
together like he would be impressed he
would be nice about my singing too yeah
like I think whether I was Mariah Carey
or Jackie asre like he would have given
me the same reaction you know yeah I do
know it was he's he's really a
sweetheart okay why need you go text him
why you go host the toast with Jake I
would absolutely love to he's welcome
here
anytime and I found out something crazy
about Jake I don't know if it's like me
blowing up his
spot his name is not
Jake yeah
IRL I don't want to know what it is I'm
not going to say it because he's Jake
don't ruin the dream and I feel like if
I saw him on the street and like I said
Jake like he would respond to Jake
yeah that is crazy fun fact
okay well are you ready for our next
story I am though that was the big news
from this weekend some other news Taylor
Swift was making news she was hanging
out in New York City with Sophie Turner
and Britney Mahomes as I want to talk
about this story as Travis Kelce played
in New Jersey so yes um tury has an
important anecdote to share with the
class about how she missed hanging out
with taylored but she went out to dinner
with her Pals including Britney Mahomes
and two other Wags in New York City
while the boys were off playing in
Germany for a football game the alist
group were photograph leaving Bond
Street sushi on Saturday night and then
they went to a birthday party at Simon
Huck's birthday party yeah so here's the
thing I knew I wasn't going to be able
to for Simon is a good friend of tury so
of course it begs a question tury Were
you invited to Simon's birthday of
course oh my God clear the record I was
invited and you weren't there
because cuz I was with Jake F sa Farm
cuz she was working and she was on her
way home from Vegas and she didn't go to
the party and she didn't party with
taylored never in my life did it occur
like I I would never would have thought
she would have been there Simon's so
close with Kim Kardashian so I figured
like first of all she would never be
there second of all I thought she was
like headed out on Eros tour
International I feel like it's been like
it starts any day now yeah but she had
one last night with the girls so do you
think Taylor wasn't the primary invite
someone no I don't think she was invited
so she was at Bond Street Sushi which is
literally next door to to zerob bond
which is a private members Club where
she goes all the time and that's where
the birthday party was oh that's where
the birth oh okay okay so I'm sure they
went next door for a drink and heard
like oh there's a Fab party downstairs
and I'm sure some of the girls in
Simon's crew I mean in Taylor's crew
know Simon and were probably invited yes
and brought Taylor along and she's just
like kind of a down for anything kind of
girl and she might not no she probably
knows who that Simon's friend G I feel
like it's I feel like she didn't know
and like she probably doesn't care yeah
I'm so upset
the thing is is there's a reality in
which I wasn't working this weekend and
I went to Simons and one of my new
things in like my OIC era is like I
can't really drink that much so I've
been going home from places like a
little bit early and there's a reality
in which like I drank a little bit got a
little nauseous and went home cuz that
happens to me now and there's a reality
in which I went and missed Taylor and
let me tell you how much [__] worse
that would have been I
agree so I have to acknowledge all the
possibilities and be grateful that that
wasn't my reality and I'm not going to
call her out but that did happen to
Amanda hirs right she's not on OIC sorry
she just left early Miss Taylor and I
know she's like reeling from it right
now right and that's worse than having
been previously and I don't want to make
Amanda feel worse than she already does
by saying her reality is worse than mine
but I'm sorry Amanda it is yeah and you
just need to cope in whatever way you
can because also like you're bigger
Swifty than Amanda so it's hard this is
harder for you and here's the thing it
feels like there's just this sort of
cosmic energy that's keeping me in
Taylor Swift apart like for real well it
begs the it begs the question have you
ever seen tury and Taylor in the same
room it does beg the question why can't
they be in the same room are they the
same person no it's because there's
cosmic energy keeping us apart like the
universe doesn't want it it's like when
two magnets the same
elk of the same
magnitude and that's what you are you
the magnit should have tailored but I
did see the erist tour last night the
movie I haven't seen it yet which is so
crazy cuz we spent hours on this podcast
talking about should I go Friday night I
had tickets for Friday night and
Saturday day I didn't go to either
because Saturday day
was your book signing but I didn't know
that so I gave away my Friday Night
tickets to a toaster because I was like
you know what I think I'd rather go
Saturday day when it's like not as
chaotic feel like less people would go I
didn't end up going either then you know
the world got away from me things were
very difficult I was going through a
difficult time I wasn't ready honestly
to be I didn't want it to be a
distraction I wanted to really enjoy it
and yesterday I went and let me tell you
it's
spectacular it might might be better
than the erist tour in person honestly I
know that sounds insane but that's just
cuz I'm like a lazy slob and like
sitting and I went to a theater where
you could order food so sitting and like
laying down and getting to like Vibe
with food and uh you didn't want to be
up and dance like I feel like I didn't I
didn't and the thing is I was in a
theater there was two other people in
the theater and they were like six rows
behind me like I could have danced and
screamed it was so loud you couldn't I
was thinking I'm like how annoying is it
if people are going to be like scream
singing you can't hear anything like
it's so loud and I really didn't have
any interest in getting up and jumping
around that's interesting I feel like I
W be tapping my foot oh and but no by
the way don't get me wrong I was doing
this you know like sitting like arms and
hips but I just feel like I would want
to Channel all of that serotonin
inhalation like yes but because it was
so up close and personal you saw so you
were so fixated on the details I
couldn't stop staring at her hair and
nails cuz it's clear that she filmed two
nights or maybe three and like spliced
some together cuz there's one night
where she has a chip in her manicure and
like it was literally all I could look
out during tolerate it CU it was really
up close um and then her hair like which
starts out pin straight towards the end
between like the elements and the sweat
and the dancing and the jump juming she
has like a full-blown like curly head of
hair F folklore and it was just fun to
watch it progress like there were so
many details and also I saw the show so
many times but there were still elements
of the show like the pyrot Technics the
screens the dancers The Outfits things
that I really missed so I was really
focused on it I wasn't like wanting to I
wanted to watch got it so I was not
going to see it because I was hoping to
go to the concert but maybe I should
just see the movie and if I make it to
the concert we're going in Miami like
you need to see it first I have to see
the concert first you're saying you have
to experience it cuz I know and you
haven't like seen like spoilers on Tik
Tok you have no idea what you're walking
into which is so rare I have a like I
saw your stories and stuff but yeah like
I I don't I don't know this this show
backwards and forwards yeah you should
wait but then you should also see the
movie I can't wait till the movie is
like available on you know DVD like I
need to purchase it okay that was my
original plan so I'll stick to my
original plan yeah stick to your
original plan so anyway she was out with
the GES and her friendship with Britney
Mahomes is just really getting serious
really BL I love that I love that like
well for her relationship romantically
with Travis but I'm really interested in
like the the Redemption era of Britney
Mahomes Britney Mahomes became like
disliked for literally no reason but she
was too excited and too
happy yeah honestly she that's her and
Taylor could be perfect friends no I'm
sure they actually have a lot in common
yeah we're excited about things that we
like right and people find us like
annoying for it but we're not we're just
excited right I like this for Britney I
I'm
deeply like traumatized talking about
this story because it could have been me
I could have been there there was videos
footage of Taylor they played shake it
off she was dancing Sophie Turner was
there I happen to know Sophie Turner not
like personally but like we follow each
other on Instagram we've dm'd we've met
so that could have been my point of
entry oh my God Sophie hey and then
Sophie's like oh hey Sophie you Taylor
this is my friend Claudia like I saw the
whole thing how it could have happened
and it didn't and I don't want to talk
about it anymore I'm sorry
tury I mean there was nothing I could
have done you know no you were working
State Farm needed you Jake needed you we
needed you it will happen the way that
it's meant to happen like that wasn't it
yeah
also did you watch football yesterday I
did good stuff I thought I saw the
Frankfurt game oh you did I missed that
one I saw a little bit of Eagles Cowboys
can't talk about it because my husband
was upset
and then I saw bills
Bengal oh I didn't see that I saw but I
don't know who won I I fell asleep
before it
ended yeah no yesterday wasn't like a
fire day because the Jets are playing
tonight and the ners had a bye week and
I said to Ben I was like oh I wonder who
the ners are playing and I said oh I
looked at the schedule and they weren't
on it so I said oh they have a byee he
goes you know what a bye is no I was
like I'm literally the number one
football fan in the world like get with
the program it's so crazy how we're just
like taking over their thing yeah no
it's mine now and I it's kind of like
what I did to your Marissa to monologue
like I'm doing to football with the boys
and I'm just manifesting like I want I'm
putting it out there I want to go to the
Super Bowl like I think we should go in
where Viva Las Vegas maybe sa arm wants
to take me there too via Las Vegas by
the way I need to issue a correction and
this is really important because when we
were talking about The Flintstones and
we were like why would they go to Viva
Las Vegas it was Viva Rock Vegas which
Rock Vegas not Las Vegas right which is
much more sympatico with the movie
because they're living in the Stone Age
so they go to Rock Vegas
duh duh so I educated myself I intend to
do better and I will just be trying my
absolute best going forward where you
listening though I think that was the
problem that I wasn't yeah it's so true
I wasn't listening in hindsight we can
see that's where you went wrong you
can't learn if you don't listen ain't
that the truth are you ready for our
next story yes a little Kardashian news
Courtney Kardashian has likely given
birth to baby boy Rocky she is over the
moon about her son's birth after the
pregnancy took a stressful turn so
earlier this week people exclusively
revealed that she and her husband Travis
Barker welcomed their first baby
together now a source tells people that
Courtney is in love with being a mom to
a newborn again she's over the moon
about her son's arrival her pregnancy
took a stressful turn towards the end
she's happy to just be able to snuggle
her baby now she feels so blessed this
is such a fabulous story like this whole
journey for Courtney from like really
wanting to have a baby and doing all the
things the IVF and and it not taking and
then getting naturally pre it's so
beautiful yeah and it's so inspiring
honestly and I literally love this
journey for her I do too and I really am
excited for her to start whenever she
decides to be sharing like whether it's
on the show or on her Instagram like I
just want to see her in this moment
because we know how badly she like
wanted a child with Travis and there's
just like so much love there and to see
her like be a mom for the fourth time
even like how what is she doing the same
what is she doing different I feel like
when she became a mom the first three
times that kind of ushered her into her
clean era and I just would love to like
know what she's up to like what are the
baby product Rex like What's the 411 um
maybe that's just like the mama and me
but I'm really excited to see her share
more yeah I agree I think it's so crazy
that we know the baby's name it's so
like regular degular of her which I love
and wait what was the other thing I was
going to say oh and in terms of like her
complications we don't really know what
happened I do feel like that'll probably
be saved for the show right yeah or
she's going to choose not to share which
she absolutely does not have to she had
said that she will share when like she's
more ready and probably a little more
out of the wood so certainly not before
like she had the baby so I think she'll
share I just don't know if she's the
type who would like save it for the show
or she would be like you know I'm not
you know selling my story like I'll
share when whatever medium I feel like
it push.com a letter from the editor
right yes of course I feel like it'll be
on the show yeah that probably is the
best medium for it because she could
share like take as much time as she
needs uh so of course you
know curious but I'm glad everything is
okay and that baby is here baby is here
baby Rocky I love the name Rocky and I
think this is Fab I love this era for
Courtney like she's kind of she's having
like a Redemption era herself as well
yeah in my
eyes yeah uh like Britney
Mahomes yeah it's nice so
mlove maslove I hope the baby is you
know all good and I hope Mom's doing
well I hope Mom's doing well next story
a little more Kardashian news because we
were speculating about Kylie Jenner's
new clothing line Kai page six is
reporting that the clothing line made $1
million in the first hour on launch day
damn so the reality star appears to have
another another successful business
venture on her hands a representative
for Kai confirmed to page six on Friday
that the brand surpassed $1 million in
sales in its first hour on launch day
alone people was the first to report the
news the project premiered on Wednesday
with a collection of affordable faux
leather
items um is that considered good like
obviously a million dollars is like a
ton of money but I'm saying for this
level of celebrity like is this good I
think so okay I feel like if it wasn't
something to brag about they wouldn't be
bragging about it they wouldn't share
the figures right but a million dollars
in an hour like no other clothing brand
is doing that really no I am curious
like what Kylie swim launch was like
like for her is this for her other
businesses like I feel like it's better
than Kylie swim maybe not as big as like
the first lip kit launch I don't even
know what that was but she only had like
maybe 10,000 of each color I don't know
if there was a million dollars to be
made yeah that's true so I think I think
this is good to or else they wouldn't be
telling us yeah yeah yeah so interesting
I saw somebody doing a try on haul do
you know that guy Charles gross from Tik
Tok let's talk about it I don't you
don't know him let's talk about he's
like very high fashioned he's so like
funny um what did he think so he tried
on the pants the big coat he loved the
coat he said the pockets were a little
shallow though and he didn't love the
pants but they looked good but he didn't
love them I don't know if he bought the
stuff if he was gifted the stuff the Cod
is interest to me it's very high
fashioned it's not for I would I could
never wear it it's not for really anyone
I think you should give it a shot it's
also like it's not for a 5 foot zero
person it's like so long to the floor
maybe snitch maybe snitch maybe I'll get
it for her just so I could see her in it
he did say it had a scent because it's
you know faux leather but he said it's
very common it's not like a bad scent
it's just the scent yeah speaking of
getting things for others to get me
birthday gift yet I did or did
you why are you saying it like that I
have some inside info from who no I
don't want I won't blow up anyone's spot
I did get you a present [__] so I
believe no but also like you don't owe
me a present until I see you so like if
you bought it yet or you didn't like oh
I wouldn't know and it doesn't matter
but I did I bought I purchased it about
a week ago doesn't affect me but I would
love to talk offline about who's
starting rumors about me in the family
I'll just tell you I was send I saw
something um online on Sachs Fifth
Avenue that was so me so I sent it to
someone cuz I was like if you need a
gift idea and they were like oh no I
actually want up getting finding you
something maybe send it to
Claudia okay
snitch okay
Margo when was this Rue when was this
last
night well that's so funny because I
haven't spoken to snitch about your
birthday present since last week when I
purchased right after got it okay cool
so she had old stale I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm like lying out of my teeth no I have
not gotten you a present yet I was going
to go out you're coming to New York so
like I was going to wait to give you in
person I'm not saying that you needed
that was like a crazy amount of lying
even for me I can't believe you would
lie straight to my FaceTime yeah no I
I'm going I was like literally SP going
to spend the afternoon shopping for you
well that's always fun I tried to buy
something online it's very hard you know
you just got to go in store yes and it's
fun but I really would have appreciated
that link well I decided I don't want it
um that it's not like it was a cute idea
but it's like like a little ugly and I
don't need it yet ugly yet ugly it was a
fendy logo baby carrier which is like so
me okay that's so Superfluous but like I
really don't need it want
it so no we decided no and let me ask
you a question as a mom do you
appreciate like mom gifts or do you want
like something nice personally it's all
the same to me if it's like a really
cute like Mom baby diap bag yeah like
that's for me I have to look at it every
like I'm not like oh I need it to be for
me okay cuz also everything that I use
right now like that's my reality right
right right so if you got me something
that's just like so not your reality not
my reality that would be
unrealistic it would as it is not my
reality it's not so thank you for being
honest you're welcome are you ready for
our next story if it's our next story
that's brought to you by state far
because this episode of the toast is
brought to you by State Farm the State
Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlists podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common spoiler
alert they're a reflection of you we all
know that right now our social medias
are full of two entirely different
things Jax's are giving you know
breastfeeding mama how to get the
perfect latch co-s sleeping things like
that and mine are giving you know travel
destinations you know cocktail recipes
we're just different like that and
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about it gives you
options to help you personalize your
coverage so that you can protect what
you care about most all at an affordable
price just for you so you can see more
of yourself in everything you love like
a good neighbor sa is
prices vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary let me say that one more time
like a good neighbor St Farm is there
prices vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary thank you get wels both tury
and State Farm and tury from State Farm
yes our fifth and final story some more
Viva Las Vegas news because Katie Perry
did her final Vegas show this weekend it
was a big weekend in Vegas her daughter
made uh her first public appearance at
the show Megan and Harry were there they
were they
were I woulding for Katie fans like I
could see them at Adele I'm surprised
they haven't been there I could see them
at Adell they went to Beyonce I I think
they they were rumored to go to the Eros
tore but there were never any photos and
when she went to Beyonce there was a
thousand videos so I feel like they
didn't go I agree there would have been
one photo um Katy Perry is kind of like
a pop star like deep cut yeah I
appreciate it I love Katie and I think
her music is for everyone and it's so
amazing so I understand why someone
would want to go of course that won't be
me because apparently her residency is
over and I missed it yeah I I feel like
that came and went yeah I don't think it
was meant to be like a Wayne Newton sort
of thing Seline di but it was something
she's been doing it for a while a lot of
celebs have come through Kim
and this was her final show and she put
her um her daughter on screen during a
segment of the performance she paused
and gave her a shout out before hot and
cold she said Daisy I love you so much
you're my best friend I'm so glad you're
here that is so cute I like love the the
pop star Vegas Journey you know yeah
it's very fun to watch and I feel like
at one point it became really
oversaturated but the thing with like
tickets is like the cream Rises so you
come and do two shows that's not
residency I would consider Katy Perry's
a successful residency I saw a lot of
content about it on Tik Tok I know a lot
of people went yeah I feel like she
should I hope she enjoyed herself and
would do it again at a time to theend OB
Adele's is a success she's still going I
think she's adding more you should go
like yeah I will like when I find myself
in Vegas it's truly something to say I
would love to go yeah Kelly Kelly's
there when now no
she's been like doing
residency but she hasn't been there in a
while Kelly Clarkson how do you know cuz
I like the Vegas residency Tik Tok like
that's how I know about stuff oh that's
true but I feel like remember she was
changing
lyrics oh yes well when her show went on
break over the summer and she released
her album she was doing a lot of like
things that weren't the Kelly Clarkson
show I feel like that's the only time of
year she can do stuff she's has her next
show is December 30th December 3
oh my God Vegas New Year's Kelly well we
have big we already have plans yeah
better plans no offense that if you're
in in the if you're looking for plans
for New Year's Eve that's a good plan
that's an amazing plan love that those
are the past five stories it feel as
though you absolutely need to know them
honestly absolutely and what's so
amazing is that because today's episode
was sponsored by State Farm they know
they know what's good and I told you
that the episode would have a little
surprise at the the end we usually do
this on Wednesdays but State Farm knows
how deer toasters is like the best part
of the toast every week so they've
decided to give us a bonus bonus Jonas
bonus Jonas deer farmer yeah we're going
to do deer toasters today but it's
called deer farmer because it's brought
to you by State Farm and that's cute as
hell can I be honest deer farmer greater
than deer toaster like that's an amazing
s what do you think about permanently
changing the name I personally like it
dear farmer duh I like I like dear
farmer but I like dear farmer
better vote sound off in the comments um
okay so we're doing deer toaster our
weekly advice segment where you can
write in and get advice from your
favorite girlies email us dear toasters
gmail.com or head to the toast
podcast.com to submit something for
advice where don't worry we keep it
totally Anonymous um so dear farmer are
you ready Born Ready hey girlies I've
been with my girlfriend for 7 years and
I'm ready to propose I have the ring in
everything we're both running out of PTO
as we are traveling for a few events
this year we have a destination wedding
at the end of the month and are
extending the trip for a few days would
it be wrong to propose to her days after
someone else's wedding I want it to be
special but this location is really
beautiful and I don't want it to ruin
but I don't want it to ruin our good
friend's moment either please help I
don't think it's wrong to do a few days
after the wedding especially if it's
like a beautiful location as long as
it's not like the wedding weekend maybe
wait till like the last day of your trip
but I think having like a special moment
at home is under
I agree with that I don't feel like you
need to be traveling or take time off
like I think you could do really
something really special like in your
own neighborhood like a good neighbor or
in your backyard or in your home like or
in places that mean a lot to you where
you live when your first date was right
like I think sometimes people overthink
it and you don't have to go away you
don't have to take time off you don't
have to be out of town like I kind of am
here for just a Sentimental at home
neighborly proposal
I want to say I think that's the best
advice like you don't need to overdo it
but let's say for argument sake you've
decided like this is what you want to do
whatever your girlfriend it's like very
clear she wants to get engaged in Mexico
or something whatever I think you do
have to be
careful I wouldn't share it on social
media for a couple of days like let the
Fanfare from the wedding die down also I
wouldn't do it like at the hotel I would
maybe plan a day trip to a beautiful
beach try and differentiate it as much
as possible it's fine once a wedding is
over like it's over I'm sorry you know
your time is up you've given us we've
got nine months of you know bridal
showers Bachelor parties but try and
different differentiate it as much as
possible but I do agree with Jackie
sentiment like don't overthink it
sometimes the most beautiful things and
the most meaningful things are the
simplest things and I just want to say
If This Were me the idea of like getting
proposed to like picking backing off of
someone else's weekend like you know the
flights were paid for the hotel was paid
for we're just kind of like you know
doing like what barock and chinaa tried
to do Brock and CH I would feel
more special doing something like at
home that was meant for me versus like
the piggy back yeah I agree any sort of
specialness that the the travel
destination provides is a little bit
taken away by the fact that it's for
someone else's yeah was like a two for
one sale yeah and I agree like proposals
are so intimate and so special honestly
I feel like it's one of the most special
parts of the wedding planning process
it's before all the torture starts
there's that element of surprise and to
do it in a simple way I actually I agree
with Jackie I think that's some of the
best advice yeah don't overthink it if
so I would do like I personally I would
prefer not on someone else's dime
technically okay I love this we're not
on our own dimes that we're already
spent for another cause yeah hey Jack sh
Bryson strice I love this submission
okay I'm 28 and single a popular reality
show dating show is coming to my city
and I'm thinking about sending in an
application I know the show is so
cringey and everybody on it is so
thirsty but same should I send in the
application and risk being embarrassed
on National Television or continue to be
a common or lay person continue doing
the typical boring life also it's just
hard out here to meet someone feels
impossible sometimes any thoughts are
welcomed Love You by okay definitely
It's Love is Blind because they are the
show that goes City to City and I would
say and it's cringy do it same you got
to take risk I just read Molly May's
book and she was saying how she was
thinking about going on La violence and
she knew of course like it could she was
building up this influence her career
and like this could take her down and
she could embarrass herself and be
ruined or she could find success with it
in a number of different ways you know
with her career she found love and if I
hadn't just read that book maybe I would
say like it's not worth it but I'm going
to say go ahead don't embar don't I mean
it's hard you know never know how
they're going to edit you but try to
carry yourself with Grace and respect
and don't do anything that you wouldn't
be proud of and if they edit you to be
someone that you're not it's out of your
control but the things that are within
your
control be you I also just feel like the
fact that you're thinking this through
so much and you know the possibilities
like obviously you listen to the toast
we talk a lot about like reality TV The
Good the Bad the Ugly you I feel like
you have a good head on your shoulders
to your fact that you're really like
considering this heavily and not just
doing it oh yeah I'm going to get a
thousand Instagram followers like you're
thinking about a lot I feel like makes
me think you're like a very self-aware
person and I think a lot of the times
the people who come off the worst on
reality TV lack that self- awareness but
it seems like you have that yeah but I
think also the people who go on real
reality TV like think that they are
going they never expect that they're
going to come off the way that they do
whether it's because of their own
actions or they've been edited a certain
way but like even if say you came off
badly like it's really just a moment in
time these things are so cyclical they
just like you know are out of the news
even like who is the last scandalous
person on Love is Blind Irena what did
she even do I don't remember it's so
true it's fine life goes on and I think
if you really want to take the risk like
go for it yeah no there's by the way
there's risk and there's reward
here I think you should do it also you
have to come on the toast you have to
make it all the way be such a big star
from it come on the toast tell us
everything and don't talk to anybody
else in the press and mention on the
show as much as you can like how you
love this podcast and like wear your
merch we'll send you merch we'll send
you merch wear it in the Pod every day
yeah in the Pod all right our third and
final hey
Farmers hi girlies I'm in my toddler mom
era and we're embarking on different
sports teams for our kids we live in an
affluent area and we are all by all
means doing well financially we feel
happy and we feel complete however the
more and more I attend my daughter's
soccer practice and games she's four by
the way I'm starting to feel really
uncomfortable around the other moms they
aren't super friendly and I get the
feeling they just think I'm like a slob
Kebab since I'm not dribing in diamonds
and designer Brands which is just not my
vibe I'm more at leisure we're at soccer
practice there's also just a 90% chance
chance I'm just projecting and they
don't even notice me but I still want to
get an outsider's opinion on how to
handle the situation you you can't know
until you talk to them like if you're
just vibing it could be your own
insecurity like you you have to know for
sure that they like think you're a slob
before we can properly hate them yeah
you could be judging them like based on
what they look like b as just as much as
you think that they're judging you but I
will say I was actually just talking to
a bunch of moms about this sort of thing
the other day and how like each of them
has had an experience with like mean
girl moms in their Community or whatever
and and there are a lot of other people
who feel this way so maybe if those
women like are what you think they are
there has to be other women who feel the
way that you do at the soccer practice
like go meet them go talk to them cuz
like um it's a very Universal feeling to
like it's really feels like high school
all over again and I was just having
this conversation with some other women
who all were feeling this way it's like
I would never expect that they would
feel that way too that's so funny like
Mom culture it's like a hierarchy yeah
no it's literally High school but I just
want to say like don't start like buying
diamonds and dressing differently cuz
that's how like one of my books starts
you know a murder mystery she tries to
keep up with the women in the
neighborhood she takes it too far she
sleeps with someone husband next thing
you know she's dead or she's the killer
right like that don't it's a slippery
slope you know that that high life that
like Rich mom neighborhood we're too old
to pretend to be people that were not
it's so true like you're you're raising
a daughter what would you tell your
daughter to do yeah no and like we are
who we are at this Point like so true
don't change who you are for someone
else ever period period so that was your
bonus Jonas dear Farmers episode brought
to you this whole episode was brought to
you by State Farm thank you State Farm
for bringing me to Bravo con thank you
for fabulous episode Jax happy birthday
Jakey from State Farm thank you so much
thank you to every rest of your day who
has messaged me and sent me well wishes
on my birthday I feel I feel it I'm so
glad I'm wrap this up I'm G to wrap this
up wrap it up
thanks so much to stay farm for
sponsoring the special episode of the
toast I've said it once and I'll say it
again and I'll say it as many times as
until you guys get it through your thick
heads like a good neighbor St V is there
love you you so much for listening to
the toes okay bye love you
bye